Then I started seeing the clips and Owens, man, you're a piece
of crap, brother. All right. And and and if I was anybody, I
wouldn't turn my back on Owenser. So, I mean, he took Snake to
the next level. >> Hillary Clinton, Barack Obama, all of
these people smell like sulfur. They're all demons.
>> Stop talking about Israel right now. >> Oh, it
was straight out of Tel Aviv, >> Yeah. Benjamin, my boss.
>> Are you sure it wasn't Jerusalem? >> Stop right
now. >> Or Washington DC. >> Owen thinks his new
franchise is going to be talking crap about me. He thinks his
new franchise is going to be running down this fabled operation.
This incredible crew and our supporters that are the info war.
>> I don't know why Owen's producers cut to a picture of
JD Vance touching the western wall. Okay, the whailing wall here.
JD Vance touching the wall. >> Well, guess what, buddy?
You can up a rope. No matter what happens to this office with
the name Info Wars, we're going to go on forever thanks to the
listeners and the viewers. God bless you
Owen Schroyer,
somebody we refer to as basically the number two
at Infowars,
>> has decided to leave InfoWars. Okay, he posted this
video yesterday, middle of the day yesterday. And Alex Jones
didn't comment on it until today. And let me tell you, Alex Jones
is not happy about this. Okay, Alex Jones kind of freaked the
out about this guy. If you don't remember Owen Shroyer, he is
famous. Okay, Owen
Shroyer
interview campus. Let's see if I can find one of his old videos.
Okay, one of his old old videos. >> Donald Trump said on
this video that he likes kissing pretty women and that >> you
don't.
>> Sir, let me Can I finish my >> You like kissing
ugly women? >> Excuse me. Can I finish my statement, please?
Thank you. I don't appreciate that either. Um, what I was saying
was
>> you don't even see Owen there. So, that's a little weird.
We got any other uh we got any other Owen Shroyer moments here?
I'm looking for older stuff. Older stuff. Older stuff. Destroys
SJW and immigration. This is like the kind of >> should
not be answering the phone because Trump's policies to try to
ban immigrants was so scary. >> Stop. I need to stop you.
>> Your rhetoric is so wrong. Immigrants. What are you
talking about? What has he done to immigrants? What has he done
to >> This is the he did. But he did this back when like
Ben Shapiro was touring college campuses. He did this for years
and somehow he ended up at Infowars. I don't really know how.
He just became conspiracy, I guess. But recently,
he's been almost a little too conspiracy for Alex Jones.
That's like where the split has come is Owen Troyer might be
a little too extreme and he's painting himself as too extreme.
And I think Alex Jones doesn't like that. The way he sort of
painted his exit here is Owen Schroer is saying, "I think Alex
doesn't want me to comment on certain things." I think Alex I
think I'm a little too too much for Alex. Okay, I got to go.
I'm being held back. HK97, I have that video. It's not the time
for that video. Okay, it's not the time. Wait, maybe it is the
time. Maybe I'll throw it up there. Okay, maybe I'll throw it
up.
>> Where do I have that? Oh, maybe I didn't grab that link.
I didn't grab that link. Oh, no. But I did have it. I had it
here. Okay. I had that through somebody else. But I'll I'll open
the Chief Trumpster one because I think this is from what a month
ago.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> But I want to get >> I had this
five months ago. Okay. I had this this video is in the replies
of one of the other things as I was checking this story out.
This is about two months ago. Okay. Owen Troyer talking to Nick
Fentes.
And let's take a look at let's take a look at Alex Jones's response
to some of their conversation, the direction it was taking. >> But
I want to get back to what you were saying about college cuz
I think it's uh >> Hold on. Hold on.
>> Hold on. Hold on a second. >> Hold on a second.
>> So, if you can't hear that,
very drunkenly. Not I don't know about that. Very fatly. No,
not that either. Hold >> I think I might be pregnant. >> I've
got cravings for microwave McDonald's. A cold and unready turned
loving it. >> I Thank you, Don. Thank you, Mr. President.
Okay. Thank you for the donation. Thank you for the five. Really
appreciate it. Let's go.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, dude. So, Alex Jones comes in
here and he uh he seems to not be liking the convo. >> I
just got a call from Tel Aviv.
Just got the call.
Stop talking about Israel right now. >> Oh, it was straight
out of Tel Aviv, >> Yeah. Benjamin Yeti, my boss. >> Are
you sure it wasn't Jerusalem? >> Stop right now. >> Or
Washington DC. >> I'm ordering you. >> Or uh Trump
Gaza International. >> I'm in her every day showing up.
I don't know why Owen's producers cut to a picture of JD Vance
touching the western wall. Okay, the whailing wall here. JD Vance
touching the wall. I don't know why the producers cut to this
at this exact moment. Difficult to say.
>> Did you uh Are you going to take the trip, Alex? You
want to go touch the
>> I would actually I would I would love to go to Egypt.
I'd love to go to Israel. >> I could I could arrange that
for you. >> I want to go see the Great Wall of China. I'm
gonna work with Xiinping. >> Yeah, I know. I would love
to go see Gol Gotham where Christ was crucified. >> I would
love to do all that.
>> Kiss the wall >> like Vance. >> Nick knows.
Nick knows. Nick knows the real questions. Okay.
>> You know, probably Yeah. I mean to troll people. Yeah.
>> That'd be a good troll. That'd be a pretty good troll.
>> That's probably to troll people. I'm sorry. You can
just tell from Owen's reaction that he's already picked. Okay.
He's already super picked at Alex Jones in general and that he
thinks that's a total cope response right there. Right. It's
a total cope response from from everything I can see from Owen.
Owen doesn't want to make eye contact. Owen's clearly annoyed
the second Alex walks >> That'd be a pretty good troll.
>> That is I would do the opposite thing. I would refuse
to touch the wall to troll >> No, listen. That's a thou
That's That's a Titus destroyed that in 70 AD.
So, you can't hate those people. And and you know, we we say
we're not Judeo-Christian. And
>> you can't hate, dude. I I can just imagine if you guys
don't know Nick Fuentes's opinion, in his opinion, um the people
who killed Jesus, okay, are basically basically Judaism was like
a a a different like, you know, multi-
multi- I guess thought collective. It wasn't like exactly one
sort of line of thought. And then the Pharisees helped get Jesus
killed. And this is his opinion, by the way. The Pharisees helped
get Jesus killed. And then uh forsaical teachings lead to Talmudic
Judaism lead to like rabbitical Judaism. And and rabbis in like
this this word of mouth teaching that they have that turns into
modern day Judaism. Okay. So it's like it's like the people.
How do you know so much about Nick? Cuz I I have to keep an eye
on this guy. Okay. He's a dangerous guy. So, modern rebbitical
Judaism is like sort of this descendant of the teachings of the
Pharisees who killed Jesus in Nick's opinion. And then Alex comes
in, he's like, "You can't hate the people from back then in 70
AD." And Nick's probably sitting there like, "Uh, want to bet
they our Lord Alex, what are you talking about? I can't I just
I can just imagine how this looks like cope to anybody who's
ever listened to Nick or anybody who is, you know, entertaining
any of these deeper conspiracies, right? >> You can't hate
those people." And and you know, we we said we're not Judeo-Christian.
I know that we are
>> But the point is it does Abraham religion and all that.
We can't you even hate the Jews of 2000 years ago. My point is
Netanyahu. >> Are we having a history discussion now? >> Do
we have to do this now? >> You know, it's because we disagree
with a bunch of bad stuff Israel does. We don't have to hate
people. What's wrong with the solidarity? You know, JD Vance
also goes to the Catholic Church. He's >> Come on, Nick.
Come on, Nick Fuentes. Why you got to hate these?
Why can't you just love these, Nick? Why can't you just love
these?
You gotta hate these. You even hate the 2,000 years ago, Nick.
Come on, Nick. Come on, man. Come on. Show a little love for
the
>> You go say hi to the Pope or whatever. My point is you
think somebody's >> the producers.
Okay. Why are you going full screen to the Vance touching the
wall picture now? >> If they go do the >> [__]
are you doing? >> Well, Vance visits the Pope. >> Okay,
the producer's an op. The producer does not work for Alex Jones.
It's over. >> Happens. Pope dies. >> Oh, you think
he killed him? >> He visits India. Nuclear war is about
to >> There was I I >> He dropped the trophy. He
broke the >> Is he the Antichrist? >> Isn't it funny
though how nobody's talking about that Pakistan India situation?
It's like it barely There was a huge the border. >> Wait,
did did JD meet the Pope right before the Pope died?
>> That's crazy. >> They didn't even talk about it.
>> They're threatening nuclear war with each other. >> they've
been doing that for years. But it's like, >> wait a minute.
We're not How do we tie that into Israel? How do we blame >> They're
working with India. >> It's true. >> That is true.
Right. >> So, it's Israel's fault.
>> You said it. You said it, not me. >> Yeah. All
right.
>> But I want >> Yeah. All right. All right.
>> Uh, even as an old man, even when he's completely in
shape,
Alex Jones still a streamer at heart. Okay. Still has no ability
to coordinate himself. Totally misses this high five. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. That's awesome. All right. So, that is two, sorry,
five months ago. Five months ago. I'm guessing right around the
time the IndiaPakistan stuff was kicked out
with the air strikes going on either side.
All right. So, we had that today, yesterday rather. Owen Shroyer
posts this whole stream. He goes into a lot of detail, but I
think the first 15 to 20 minutes is all we need here. Okay. Owen
talks about his leaving from Infowars and all this and it was
like a sad moment. I'm sure a lot of people who watched Info
Wars were were sad about it and I I'll let him get into it because
I have not actually seen the uh the whole thing
but I've seen some of this stuff from Alex a little bit later.
Alex is not happy about this. Okay, >> ladies and gentlemen,
friends and >> Oh, this is very quiet. I forgot. >> Owen
Shroyer live episode 115. Why I am done at Infowars. This may
come as a
>> By the way, the audio on this is just dog. It's so quiet.
I have no idea why is it set up this way. Like I have I have
this at 600% through an extension and maxed out on Twitter and
this is as loud as it goes. >> The announcement for you
tonight. It may not. I'm going to break it all down. I feel I
owe you an explanation of what's been happening. I'm going to
let people get caught up before I really get into the juice here.
Um but I'm going to let you know it's official. I >> the
what the >> am now done at InfoWars >> and I'm going
to let you know why coming up in uh just a minute. First Fuel
hemorrhage because why not? >> Memories are just
>> No way. No way. He shows up to his stream and he's like,
I'm just going to play this fuel song right now. I'm just going
to go with it, guys. I'm feeling it. Uh Twitter video just broke.
1 minute 43 into the stream. All right.
I've got I've got another clip I think of him just uh he just
plays a lot of fuel. The he does just play the whole >> Destroy
your life.
>> Why I am done at Infowars. >> I'll be honest,
this guy I feel like had kind of a bright career like he was
like an upandcomer on the right wing. I And I didn't think he
was like pigeon holing himself. He's like a true conspiracy believer
because I don't think he had to pigeon himself in pigeon hole
himself into going to Infowars and he just did,
right? Like I think he could have gone and done way more mainstream
right-wing politics and been like popular. Like he was doing
a lot of coverage around the Ben Shapiro stuff. He was making
a lot of money. He was getting a lot of views and he kind of
just went to Infowars and dropped off the map.
Not I'm not joking. Like I think this guy's quite popular. I
would put him below
Lauren Southern but above a lot of other people. No, no, no.
I'm talking about like 10 years ago. Slime 712. Like 10 years
ago, this guy was like an upandcomer in political media, right?
He believed in Alex and he feels abandoned. He believed in Alex.
I I'm not joking that when I say that like I wouldn't be shocked
if this guy had offers from a bunch of like upcoming right-wing
publications, platforms to try to like to be like a big voice
in the right wing. And I think he just totally
loved Alex Jones or or believed in Alex Jones and he joined Infowars
and he fell off the [__] up. Anyway, we continue.
there's a reason why I'm doing this tonight. There's a reason
why I have to do this tonight and I'm I'm going to explain it
all. uh because that's what you deserve as my audience as >> I
believe if I'm if I'm reading the tea leaves correctly. I've
not watched the whole thing. I believe so everybody's saying
he's a true believer. I believe this is like where the belief
stops. Like I think he's basically come to the conclusion in
his head that Alex Jones is some kind of controlled opposition,
not aggressive enough, not
not willing to shake things up enough, which is crazy
in and of itself. But
Alex dubbed Owen his era parent many times. Well, he was like
the number two at Infowars by far. Like he was the next guy.
>> As people who have supported me over the years, you
have you have prayed for me as people that >> Okay. So,
Nv saying that actually those old street interviews he's already
with Infowars. This is his first job in politics. He did local
sports reporting before this. Okay. But then I'm still positive
from Infowars he could have gone elsewhere because he was blowing
up. He was very popular. I think he he had a lot of he was getting
a lot of views on YouTube. He must have gotten banned off of
YouTube at some point. I don't know when he got banned. sent
me letters when I was in prison. Just just all of it. You know,
I'm grateful for my audience. I consider myself extremely blessed.
And quite frankly, I consider myself extremely blessed for my
time at Infowars. And I'm sorry that it had to end so abruptly,
if you want to say that. But about an hour ago,
I got off the phone with Alex and um that was it. That was it.
So, I owe it to you. Do I feel I owe it to you, the audience,
to explain what went wrong
and why I decided to leave and how that went down.
Right. He's the guy who did the You're a white male. White male
interview. I He's the guy who did this interview, right? You're
a straight white male. Come on. Where is it? Are we We really
can't find this. Somebody link me the interview. You're a white
male.
A white male meme.
You're a white male. This is >> I have done my research.
I've done my >> He's the guy from this. Remember this >> white
male? Yes. In America? Yes. Look at all the uh black people that
are
That's not a issue compared to the black people that are police.
>> Okay. So, this is memes. This is big memes like a decade
ago. Okay. And this is on Troyer's interview. He was blowing
up with the the anti-SJW content back then. All right. Just trying
to convince you guys that you should know who this guy is, okay?
>> And just just to be perfectly clear.
>> Is it a decade ago? >> That's how I wanted it
to be. >> It's ancient. >> I want to be perfectly
clear about something and I'll I'll explain this in a little
more detail. I did not want it to go this way. Okay? I tried
everything.
I tried everything so that it wouldn't
go this way.
But I am left with no choice but to come on here tonight and
make the announcement. Just so you understand and then I'll kind
of give a little bit more detail. You may have noticed I've been
taking a lot more time off. Specifically, you may have noticed
how on Thursday
I walked off the show mid show. is about an hour into the show
and just so you understand what happened and if you watched the
InfoWars War Room you've seen this before so it's not like it's
anything new but um you know Alex was disrupting the show and
he wanted me to cover something and he wanted me to get a guest
on. I'm in the middle of the show while it's going on as as you
see so many times.
>> About college cuz I think it's uh >> Hold on.
Hold on.
>> Hold on.
>> Starting to see where Yeah. starting to see where a
lot of this I don't have the clip he's talking about. Okay. I
don't have the clip where he walked off, but I'm starting to
see where like this resentment was building up over time. I feel
like if I can fill fill it in a little bit. Do we have the clip?
Does anyone have the clip of when he actually walked off, guys?
Back to this
ground.
I I kind of just reached my point of no return and so I just
walked off the studio.
Um, now I will say it was a little it's a little upsetting to
me um that he went on and said that I had a family emergency.
I did not have a family emergency. There was no family emergency.
Um, I didn't appreciate people reaching out to me thinking that
something bad had happened, including my own parents.
Um, so there was no family emergency. I I walked off the show.
I've never done that before in my life
and that's not how I operate. That's not who I am. But I just
I felt powerless in that moment. And the only power I had was
just just to walk off because I couldn't do another thing
like it was 2 or 3 weeks ago when I came back and did that comedy
bit. I couldn't do another thing where I just say, "Oh, go to
rebroadcast." It was it was whatever. So, no, I I walked off
the show um on Thursday. Now, my intention was to go back this
week, and I made that intention perfectly clear to Alex an hour
ago. Now, I wanted to meet with Alex in the office tomorrow.
And I told him that I told him that last week after I left the
studio, he texted me and I said, "Alex,
let's talk next week."
I said, "I don't want to talk about it now. I'm done for the
week. Let's talk next week." Um, we communicated a little over
the weekend and then today I said, "Let's meet. let's have a
meeting tomorrow before your show whenever you want. Let's meet
tomorrow before your show and uh maybe we can talk this out,
work it out. And he said, "No, let's just let's just talk now."
And he so he called me. >> That's never a good sign, by
the way, when someone's like when you're like, "Hey, I'm going
to set up we we need to cool our heads, figure out what we're
going to say, let's move forward." And someone goes, "No, let's
just talk now." That person is like upset. They want to they
want to end. Okay. Alex Jones doesn't want you around anymore
at that point. If you if you want to, you should say, "No, I
want to do it tomorrow. I want to take some time." Right? They're
like, "No, I want to talk." Yeah. You got to No, we'll take some
time. We'll think about it. Okay. Um, now my
and I told them this. I wanted to go in this week. I wanted to
go in tomorrow and I wanted to finish this week and I wanted
to finish positively at Infowars.
>> you know, I I even said if if if he wanted me to kind
of stick around like a satellite to go down with the ship that
that I'd be willing to play some sort of a satellite role to
go down with the ship and be a part of that and and continue,
you know, having wearing the the the name on the front of the
jersey for at least some semblance while it's still ongoing.
And so I don't know what that means exactly. I know Alex was
bankrupt, right? I know Alex ended up getting bankrupted. I thought
they were basically selling off InfoWars and then Trump became
president and I'm not totally sure what happened. But like is
Owen implying that Owen Wars that is Owen implying that Infowars
is on a timeline or it's on like a like borrowed time? Is it
about to end or I heard it was sold again? >> Um he didn't
express >> going for sale again. Okay.
>> And so he told me that
he didn't need me and good luck and that was that.
That was that. So, I wanted to make this announcement on Infowars.
I wanted to make this announcement with Alex. Uh, that actually
meant a lot to me. That's what I wanted.
Um, I wanted to leave in a very positive fashion.
I wanted to announce it to the Infowars audience on the Infowars
airwaves. I wanted Alex and the crew and everybody to be there.
And I wanted to shake Alex's hand. I wanted to thank him for
everything. I wanted to just go down memory lane of all the things
that we've done. uh but he wasn't interested in that
and uh he said don't come in this week.
So that was that.
So now here I am um announcing that um it's done. I will not
be on Infowars.
I don't know if ever again. Um
won't be hosting the war room this week. >> Yeah, I based
on Alex Jones's reaction. Okay. I'm This seems unlikely. Okay.
It seems unlikely to be the >> I don't really know what
else there. >> So it sounds like he got fired. It sounds
like like you could say one side fired the other, but it sounds
like this is building up for a while that this wasn't going to
work out. >> To say about that
other than it's not how I wanted it to be,
but I was left with no choice. I was left with no choice. Now,
I don't know. I don't know how Alex wants to handle it.
Honestly, I hope that he just doesn't talk about it at all. And
people might view that as like a bad thing or a negative thing.
I don't I don't think so. It's if he if he wants to just sever
ties and just move on like that, I have no problem with it. So
So I don't I don't you know I I hope he doesn't make a thing
of it. I hope he's fine. He can bring it whoever he wants to
host it or shut it down. I don't really care. Um
you know I I don't have anything negative to say about Alex.
This is not what this is about. Um I have nothing but respect
and appre Okay. I you guys are saying it sounds like he quit.
It sounds like he said okay Alex you my show for like the 80th
time. I'm getting the out of here unless you like fix something.
Sounds like he wants promises from Alex and he's not getting
>> appreciation for uh for Alex and everything that we've
done at Infowars.
I'm not sure that was mutual,
but
doesn't really matter. Um, but you know, kind of kind of to give
you the longer form situation, you probably noticed that
I had not been hosting the war room a lot this month. And you
know, Alex had been coming into my show and talking about how
I'm negative and calling me a pessimist and all this other stuff,
which is which is fine. You work for Alex, you're going to get
hit with it a lot. Alex is not easy to work for, and that's fine,
you know. Um, that's okay. But,
>> okay, he says I'm too negative. He says I'm a pessimist.
Whatever. I'm too
So, I just said, "All right, you know >> I'll just take
some time off.
I'll just disappear."
And so, there's like the big allegation, I guess, within the
these circles is Alex thinks he's too anti-Trump.
You don't think Trump's getting enough done. You don't think
Trump's doing what he should do. It sounded like when Fuentes
and Shroy were talking, it's like I'm guessing there'll be conversations
here, what was this 5 months ago? Maybe not about possibly about
Iran back then, right? I'm guessing the Iran thing's been a big
thing for him, right? He doesn't want to go to war with Iran.
I'd imagine that's a big deal. Okay.
I I'm kind of looking for stuff in the background about him and
the first thing that popped up for me on Twitter was uh this
video.
>> Rabbi Schroer introduces his new tinfoil
>> Yamaka.
It blocks space lasers.
It blocks aliens from reading your brain waves. It also allows
the public to know you're a conspiracy theorist,
but most importantly, it gives you power.
So, Rabbi Royer here now more powerful than ever.
I I can't imagine why I can't imagine why. Can't imagine why
Alex might not like this. Is he mocking Is he mocking Alex here?
Um, Dan Bonino. >> I mean, Alex has put tinfoil hats on,
Right. Date on this vid. This vid was from a month ago. Less
than a month ago.
Okay. Owen Troy had enough and demands legal action for the anti-semitism
levied against him. I might watch more of this. I'm looking around
for the clip of him walking off of Infowars a couple days ago.
Okay.
>> Oh, this is not the one. I'm looking for the one where
he walks off and I can't find it here. I'm guessing somebody's
got it somewhere, right? It's got to be somewhere. Let's let
him keep talking for a little bit. >> If Alex thinks I'm
too negative, then maybe he's right. Maybe he's right. Maybe
I'm too negative now. Maybe I'm too much of a pessimist now.
Maybe I'm too anti-Trump now. Whatever. Whatever his whatever
his issue was when he kept coming in the show telling me I'm
too negative, saying I'm a pessimist on his show. I said, "Okay,
maybe he's right. I'll take some time off. I'll blow off some
steam. I'll just get out of the ring for a week and, you know,
maybe I'll come back a little more positive." And and you know,
maybe there was a level of reality to that. And I think I did
come back more positive, but uh the same issues that that I had
started up immediately as soon as I came back.
And it's not to it's not to say that I didn't have creative control
over the InfoWars War Room. Um but I mean, imagine it's like
somebody staring over your back 24/7.
And so every single day that I came back, it was either a guest
that I was told I had on at the last minute or it was, you know,
him coming into the studio. He wants me to cover this. he wants
me to cover that or I have to host his show for him because he's
not in. So, there was just there's nothing consistent for me.
I I couldn't
I couldn't do what I wanted to do, which I'll explain what I
want to do um in a second here.
So, whatever. So, I'm going through it again last week and then
>> Well, he's accusing Alex of interfing interfering with
the show. Okay. Just like not letting him run it on his own.
Alex gave him a show. I'm guessing it was a big coup for Owen
to have like his own show in prime time on InfoWars and Alex
instead of just letting him run the prime time show in Infowars
seems like Alex was constantly barging in going cover this, cover
that, run it my way. >> Last week happens and this is this
is how it's possible he would have made a >> for me. It
was like okay
uh if this is how it's going to go really what happened Wednesday
and Thursday.
So, Wednesday was the school and we get the exclusive with Kyle
Sarapin from his Fed source at about 9 or 10:00 in the morning.
Now, we get this information. We have the images. We have the
name.
The crew has already archived all of the online content, the
manifestos, the videos.
So, I mean, we got it. We got >> Now, I was supposed to
host the show, but obviously we get this exclusive. So, Alex
wanted to host the show. So, I'm like, "Okay, well, great. All
right. So, let's do this." So, it's like, uh, left to his own
devices. You think he thrives or not? I don't know. I don't know.
He probably would be better as a part of a group, but
I think a lot of people do like him. I think a lot of people
from Infowars would follow him. I think that's a major problem
for Alex. I think he will split a decent chunk of that audience
off. >> Here we go. I'm riding with Alex again, folks.
We're firing up the Millennium Falcon again. We're going into
the info war. We're taking out a Death Star again. And I know
that this is hard for people to understand from the outside looking
in. And I don't say that from an arrogant standpoint. I'm just
trying to explain to you what it's like here.
So, so when he when he's coming on Wednesday, the Jones show
that I'm hosting, and he's like, "We've got the exclusive. We're
going to break this." Everyone knows we're going to get burned.
Okay.
I mean, I don't know about Kyle. He's still kind of relatively
new to the media, but he's a fed, so he's, you know, he's a he's
a tough guy. He wears big boy pants,
but everybody in Infowars knew, oh, here's a school. We've got
the exclusive. We're going to destroy the cover up. Like, everyone
knew we were going to get burned. Everybody knew we were going
to get burned for this. And I said, "All right, Alex, I'm going
into the fire again with you. Let's do it." >> That'sed
up, right, dude? Alex? Really? You want to take point on the
school,
Alex? Could you maybe sit the one thing? There's just just one
thing I'd ask you to sit out, Alex. You want to sit out the school
[__] bro? You want to not get all of us in the ass
again? We've barely got the feds off of our ass. We've barely
got like all of these activist groups off our ass. You want to
take point on the school [__] Alex?
Really? I do kind of get it. Okay, Rhox has linked me the the
clip. Okay, this is the clip of him when he walked off the show
from before. >> So, you had this over Fox News last night.
I pulled
>> There were a ton. >> No, this is not left-wing
media. This is not liberal media. Fox News clip six have had
a gun. I know very staunch second amendment advocates who totally
agree with red flag laws. Crazy people should not have guns.
Period. End the story. Your right to a gun is not universal.
Just like even the first amendment are are literally the foundation
of our nation's constitution.
>> You it's not sacrosanct. There are limits on it. And
if you trip a red flag law, you don't get the gun. Period. End
the story. And that's something that also needs to be muscularized.
And I say that as a believer in the Second
>> all right guys, just go to a break or something. Just
go to a break. >> Okay. Someone yapping in his ear or something?
Not a fan.
Okay. No, he's Owen's literally saying that Fox sucks for playing
this clip. That's like why Owen's covering this clip. He's mad
at somebody for saying go to something else. He said he said
he's mad at Alex for Alex wanting to I don't know tick point
on this or something. Right. So he's not talking. Then he just
says all right go to break.
>> I'm promoting spike protein detoxes have saved so many
people and done all this if I >> spike protein
detoxes. Wait, is there another clip?
Hold on. The second clip is also from Fox News. Aaron Cohen,
ex-Israeli special forces agent, says, "I'm about to launch Gideon
America's What is
>> Hold on. Hold on. More >> with Owen. >> Okay.
The internet 247 using Israeli great ontology.
Okay. When this is great, there you go, guys. You're getting
your Israeli spy state.
>> Yeah. So, red flag laws are great. Uh, say conservatives.
That is until liberals get in power and say it's a red flag that
you're a conservative. So that'll come back to bite you. Um and
then this just happened on Fox News.
>> Correct. I am now about to launch Gideon, America's
first ever AI threat detection platform built specifically for
law enforcement. It's the internet 24/7 using an Israeli ontology
to pull specific threat language and then routes it to local
law enforcement. It's a 247 detective. It never sleeps and it's
going to get us in front of these attacks. Would it have
>> Yeah. I mean, I'm sorry. That's going to set off any
conspiracy person immediately, right? >> Is this guy even
saying? Okay. An Israeli great ontology. I have no idea what
the means. Okay. >> These attacks would it have picked
up on this, do you think? >> 100%. I wish you're getting
your Israeli spy state. You're getting your Skynet. You're losing
all your rights on board because they won't be honest about what
All right, we'll be back. >> I am proud to announce ultimate.
>> Okay, so all right, we'll be right back. Owen then picks
up his phone momentarily and moves it before putting it back
down, then looks down at the ground as if he's getting ready
to leave. Then there is a series of ads and clips for about 30
minutes before Alex Jones takes over the war room.
Clip starts at 5333,
goes to 59 something. Hold on. 533
>> Second Amendment to
it. some ads. Play some ads.
>> What is
the internet come back and it's okay. So the first clip he's
about to walk off. He says good to break using an Israeli grade
onology to pull force.
I am proud to announce ultimate
because even if you haven't
>> interim CEOs
so we get clips clips clips
>> when you read about actually for people >> what
is doing there >> longterm effects >> yeah it gives
you good energy boost before so if I'm going to be doing kettle
bell workouts I I do some methane blue about half hour before
gives you mental focus and I don't crash afterwards that's good
stuff I need some
How fast did it kick in? >> About 15 20 minutes ago.
Better than doing like a 5 hour energy shot cuz those will make
you crash
>> I like it better. >> Jesus, he's a animal.
>> Better than doing like a 5 hour. >> This guy's
like 70 years old. >> Shot cuz those will make you crash
>> Dude, what chemicals is Alex Jones on? Holy [__]
I thought he was just showing that didn't work before >> words.
This doesn't have the crash. >> See that? no crush. >> If
you'll just try, you'll be hooked. And we can >> These
ads are Do you remember the uh Ultra Male Vitality or Super Male
Vitality ads where he just didn't change at all? I can see why
people might buy these now. Okay, I can see why people would
buy these if if that's what he's saying are the effects. >> Funny
operation.
>> Okay, so the war room comes back because
>> You have to >> and it's uh it's Alex Jones live.
Okay, Alex Jones takes it over. >> Another press. >> Although
I think I think that was just clips. Okay, I think that was clips
before. This is where they come back. So, Alex took the show
over about a week ago as well. That's what Owen was about. Let's
uh let's see. I don't think we're going to watch too much more
of this. I think we're basically through a lot of this stuff
with Keep watching for a >> We did it.
>> Uh we broke the big exclusive. It's it's it's very likely
that if it wasn't for us that day, you never heard about the
trans you never saw the videos, the manifesto or any of it. It's
very likely that that's the case, but we knew we knew we would
get burned. We've been down this road before, especially on that
issue. Just you're guaranteed you're getting burned. You're either
getting sued or you're getting censored or you're getting the
negative headlines. So, before the show is even over, there's
multiple headlines printed up. Owen Shroyer celebrates mash.
Owen Schroyer celebrates dead kids. I might get to that later
on.
Whatever. It's part for the course. So, there you go. So, I got
burned. So, I I rode into the fire on Wednesday. We broke the
big exclusive. I fired up and I got in the co-pilot seat of the
Millennium Falcon with Alex Jones for one more ride, knowing
I was going to get shot out of the sky, knowing I was going to
get burned. But, hey, all right. It's the Info War. I said, "All
right, Alex, you want me? Let's go. Let's do it." And we did
it. And we did it. And then I get the negative headlines. Okay,
fine. I anticipated that. And then the next day,
I have to deal with the same stuff of him breaking into the show.
He's he's now he's he's on a speaker phone and they ask he's
asked the crew to bring him. I It's It's just It's just a
It's just a cluster bomb.
So, I had prepared a three-hour show. I thought since we just
did what we did the day before that I could do a three-hour show
and and babysitter wouldn't be looking over my shoulder. I was
wrong. It happened and I just said, "I'm out. I'm just done."
So if you don't want me So okay, I think this is very clear.
Just getting his toes stepped on. Alex doesn't want to hand off
any part of the show. Alex wants to be the star the whole time.
Owen wants his own part. He wants his own piece. He wants to
be able to be his own guy. And that's not going to happen on
Infowars. Many such cases where there's like two big people on
a program right now. I will say Owen is maybe a bit getting a
little too big for his boots. Like I don't think Owen has 1/100th
the name recognition that Alex has, right? Even on Infowars,
he doesn't. Like even running InfoWars, I don't think most people,
you ask almost anyone, I don't think most people would be aware
that Owen was running one of their major shows, right? Infowars
is Alex Jones to most people. So I understand he wants to be
able to like he wants to be able to go on his own, but he is
not Alex Jones. And a man, we'll we'll see. Listen, Alex was
uh Alex was quite upset with him. Okay. Alex was very upset.
Let me let me take a second to go find Let me go find the teaser
for the Alex bit, okay? Because we'll watch probably the whole
Alex show. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Yeah, we'll
watch we'll watch this. Okay, this is the clip that has going
around.
Jesus Christ, this guy's going off.
The bot's going off. Get him out. Get the bot out.
minute show. >> Jesus, that bot was going crazy.
They're banned. They're gone. They're dead.
I think they're dead. Are they not dead? I definitely just banned
that guy. Yeah. Okay, he's banned. He's gone. He gone.
Why does Kick allow that many messages at a time? Uh because
all of their throttling for messaging is in their front-end client
and so you can't actually stop it if it's a bot. Why did they
do this? I don't know. It's kind of Anyway. All right. All right.
Uh this is uh this is just the short clip I think. Shorter clip.
Oh no, this is a this is a longer clip. So Alex Jones the next
day. Okay. Today earlier this morning, he's got two people. One
of them is Harrison Smith. I have no idea who the this guy is.
They're running their show. And Alex Jones comes in to talk a
little bit about about this throwing. Yeah. And the front incline
is stupid, but it's fine. Alex Jones comes in a little bit to
talk about Owen Shroyer's departure.
>> Oh no, he's here. We we've crossed the line. You should
launch a new independent show and claim that I censored you for
years and get a million viewers and betray me. And you're you're
allowed to lie about me anyway you want. >> You know I
love you. >> Look, let's reject the Let's reject the >> This
is this is this is a I'm using this as a case point. You understand
that? >> How much have I come in and censored you over
the years? >> Yeah. Not enough, frankly. I say >> that's
Alex's son. Okay. Um
this is so this is so cringe. If you've ever had like a big like
CEO boss guy who's like gotten into a fight with someone who
tells them that they're like a little too egotistical, they run
things, they micromanage too much, and then they come in and
they start asking the rank and file employees, "You think I micromanage
you too much? Do I tell you, bro, you're the CEO of the company?
Why is some junior developer going to tell you that you micromanage
too much? Shut the [__] up. Stop being an like an
immature like egoomaniacal maniac. All right, can you [__]
Can you chill? Can you chill?" It's dude, there's no way Harrison
Smith or anyone else who works at that company is going to tell
you that you are micromanaging too much or you do too much from
behind the scenes. Ain't nobody going to say that you have I
ever censored you. >> Never once. Literally never. >> Hey,
but hey, if you want to quit and have a publicity stunt and lie
about me, I forgive you. Okay, >> I know. I was saying
I expected Hey, David Knight did it. Owen's done it. And I I
tell I was taking the high road till I actually started watching
him. And I I was going to take the high road here until I started
watching him. and his
>> It It's like
>> I didn't It didn't feel like he was lying. It feels
like you look at those clips, it seems pretty clear that Alex
bursts onto the show and starts trying to dictate [__]
to >> Skywalkers become Can we sing a song? >> Hey,
when I go on the air, when I go on the air, I'm letting you have
it, >> This is just incurable boomers. Boomer. Okay. Can't
talk about anything without doing a sci-fi reference, a fiction
reference, a popular culture reference.
Anakus Skywalker's become Darth Vader. >> Hey, hey, when
I go on the air, when I go on the air, I'm letting you have it,
Troyer. You stabbed your brother in this operation in the back
and you're a liar. >> Can we Can we sing a song? Can we
sing a >> We're going to Can we just Kaya,
my
can we can we chill? Can we just sing a song? Dad, can we just
sing a a song,
>> We're going to take a little break here. We're going
to sing a song. I'm angry.
I've had enough of these people.
They're a bunch of Christian murdering scum running giant. >> Oh,
they're doing the Alex Jones meme song. Alex Jones meme song.
>> Factories keeping babies alive and selling their body
parts. What more do you need to know about these people? I go
out and face these scum. They literally crawl out from under
rocks. They have green. >> Dude, fat Alex Jones was just
cooler. Okay, this Alex Jones, this is the Alex Jones we love.
Lex Luthther, Alex Jones, I'm actually not as much of a fan of.
Okay, it's hard to be as much of a fan of Lex Luthther Alex Jones
as this Alex Jones. This Alex Jones was just better.
>> Satan, we want to eat babies.
I have them on video
creepy weird sick stuff. Man, >> I'm tell people don't
believe me that we sing this song. Everybody in the audience
knows this song by heart. They know it by heart. >> And
it's it's a truly beautiful thing. I don't I don't realize how
how upset Alex was over. >> It's tough. You know, look,
I mean, it's kind of a Batman and Robin situation. I really think
that they're both going to go on to do great things, but it's
it's >> Oh, yeah. I mean, I agree. >> Oh, no. I hear
him from across the room. Oh, yeah. I
I agree. >> I didn't realize how you were. Totally
>> to go and and and do innuendo that you've been censored
and controlled and got to go cuz you're talking bad about Trump
and this stuff and then later hours go, "Oh, no, he didn't censor
me." All set up to boost himself off of lying about me.
I don't ever get involved in infighting, but I've known somebody
10 years and they've been my friend, but he's gotten really dark.
Didn't talk to the crew the last two years and and and so it's
like just like a different person. I'm not here to be the villain
for somebody's lie. So, wait till you hear his phone call me
yesterday. He literally talked to me like I was a
>> Did you record that phone call, Alex? You're This guy
is such a scumbag. He's totally He's totally stabbing me in the
back. Wait until you hear the call. I I've got them on audio.
I've got them on audio. I got the tapes. I've got the >> He
was a pimp. He's like, "Yeah, well, if you're desperate, pay
me more. I'll stay, but I'm going to promote my new show on Info
Wars. Huh?
Really nice. I might do a week. I was like, man, this is really
hurting my feelings, dude. No, it's all right. You don't have
to come in. I hung up, started crying, and then he goes off and
lies about me. You piece of [__] I won't hate people
stabbing me in the back anymore. You get ready. >> So,
because that'll be okay.
If this was just content, this is actually fantastic content.
Cutting WWE promos live on air. >> clipped. You can follow
me at Rex Jones News on Twitter. And that's Rex Jones News with
a Z. Uh, very important that you follow me on Twitter. Thank
you. U
>> About me. You piece of [__] I won't hate
people stabbing me in the back anymore. [__] you.
Get ready. >> So, because that'll be >> Get ready.
Lawsuit really took the This is fun. What are you talking about?
The lawsuit took the fun out of Alex. This is really fun. Okay,
we've got the got the full Alex segment, but real quick, okay,
real quick, because I think it is from the night before, I'll
watch the Fuentes clip. Okay, I think it's from the night before.
It's from last night. >> get involved. >> He saw
he saw this clip or sorry, he saw the O the piece. Okay, and
then he got a super chat about this. Okay, I love Alex Jones,
man, but W for leaving Info Wars. I hope he has a crazy solo
run. Alex is being too damn optimistic about this administration
and it's short
cited something. I don't want to get involved in that. That's
between them
>> as someone that has >> Hold on. I just want This
is a classic Fuentes clip. Okay.
>> I don't want to get involved with in that. That's between
them. Clip length 6 minutes 26 seconds. Okay. I'm not going to
get involved. I don't really want to comment on that. That's
between them. But, you know, just I'm not going to make it, you
know, but my opin I guess my opinion is I don't want to say too
much, but cut a fiveminute promo. I don't want to say too much,
but like,
you know, I've been thinking this for a little. Had that happened
to me? It's very common.
People split up all the time. Sour difference in vision. You
know, it happens all the time. I like Owen. I like Alex Jones.
I'm not going to take a side on that one because I love them
both. I love Owen Troyer. I probably agree ideologically more
with Owen, but I have so much respect and love for Alex Jones.
He's a le a legend, a living legend. So, what happened is between
them.
I will say I don't I don't love the airing out the grievances
and I love Owen
and I understand why he did it. I get it. He's frustrated. He
didn't get a chance to address it on the air and I I but him
and Jaden broke up. Yeah, that was Scorched Earth. Okay, that
was crazy. The the Jaden Nick Fentes breakup. That was that was
Scorched Earth. That was like we're going to burn everything
down. Okay,
I don't think Owen Owen hasn't reached that point yet. Okay,
we're going to need like two to three years of just seething
hatred between them before we can put before we can put Owen
and Alex on that level. Okay, >> I understand how he feels,
but I'm a big believer in un unless there's extraordinary circumstances,
you should really not air that stuff out, you know,
because that's just the course of things. Like you're not married
to What was that? What is his breathing? >> That stuff
out, you know? >> You hear that? >> Because that's
just the course. >> Hey, can we move the mic back? Can
we get some filters on this? What's going >> You're not
married to the guy. You worked for the guy. You had a career.
It ended on a bad note.
It happened. >> By the way, I think this is like fantastic
public speaker like mannerisms where you're consistently breathing
in through your nose to, you know, keep keep on to keep on to
keep on uh talking the whole time. like you run out of air and
you do like the quick the quick breathing through the nose to
like keep talking the whole time and never ever actually break
up your speech in any way at all because you know you know it's
like he he I think he sneaks them in intentionally like that
but maybe yeah maybe he's sick recently said he won't do the
show because he's sick. He was probably a little sick when the
show was recorded. I >> you know and I don't know the whole
story but from the story that he told it didn't sound like it
justified the big
That's just me. I I'm a huge believer in discretion, believe
it or not. I'm a big believer in discretion. And I just question
what's the value in putting that out there. I I understand it's
um feels good. You're explaining your side of the story and it's
your story to tell. I mean, you you own your story and if you
want to share that, it's your prerogative. It's it's your right.
Um
there are two wolves inside of Nick Fentes. One is being the
bigger personality. He's been stabbed by somebody. he's like
close friends with like stabbed in the back. The other is like
him thinking that Alex Jones is controlled opposition and that
Owen Sher is actually his ideological ally and he wants to support
Owen, but he's like a lot of clout from Alex Jones, a lot of
clout from going on that show. [__] I think his heart's
entirely with Owen. His brain's entirely with Alex. But I question,
you know, what the value is. I think if he had come out and said,
"Look, I had to leave because him and I agree on Trump." That's
one thing. if he came out and said
>> you know, I'm leaving Inf Wars because we just have
different visions and and it's obvious, you know, he's very optimistic.
I'm very pessimistic and we just had a difference of opinion.
We split up. That would be one thing, but I don't um and I didn't
think that. So Owen is complaining, right? Owen's complaining
that like, oh, you know, Alex is over by coming on for this,
but I I'll go with him. That's probably about as bad as it got.
I think most of it was like just explaining things probably the
entire audience could see, right? I didn't get the sense that
like Owen was was leaking that's like going to harm Alex in the
future in some way. He was kind of just giving his perspective,
right? And while unprofessional, I don't see how it was like
a like sort of like a relationship ending like meltdown kind
of thing. And maybe I'm a hypocrite cuz I know I've crashed out
on people before, but so maybe that makes a hypocrite of me.
I'm not uh perfect, but I do think that discretion is something
that we undervalue. I'm a huge believer in that. Uh because we
we live in such a society where it's like, >> whoa, what
the [__] Uh disavow. Gross. >> You can't trust
anybody with anything anymore, you know?
>> you know?
>> Silly stuff. Stupid stuff. >> Jesus. Everybody's
airing out everybody
uh on on social media and gossip
and I I'm guilt I'm as guilty as the next guy, but I really don't
think it's good. I feel like, you know, a long time ago there
was something to be said about
trust and discretion and friendship and now it has virtually
zero currency, zero value. There there is no true loyalty. You
know, people say they're loyal and then the second something
doesn't work for them, they switch up completely and justify
it. And it's like, okay, so that's not loyalty.
man. Oh, there's like a saying around this, right? Oh, don't
expect somebody to be more loyal to you than
not to themselves. There's like basically you can't expect people
to sacrifice for you more than you'd sacrifice for them in any
real sense, right? And a lot of people who are big personalities
like this, especially I would imagine this the way it is for
Alex. It's the way it is for Nick, right? Not just bank account.
I don't think Nick expressed loyalty from people he gives nothing
back to, right? Like you just feel you you have devotion to Nick.
He expects loyalty from you. It's one way. He's not taking a
fall for you. He's not he's not doing anything that puts himself
out for you. And he expects loyalty from people. If you expect
loyalty from people like that, you've given nothing back at all.
I think that's insane. There's also like if you expect people
to like destroy themselves for you, which I think Owen kind of
did, right? Owen didn't talk to anybody about Jan 6. He kind
of got taken in. I think I think Owen probably could have gotten
himself out on Jan. I don't think anybody cared about arresting
him. I think he got arrested sort of in a way that almost nobody
else did and he just went to jail. He just ate the sentence,
right? He was just like, "Yeah, [__] it. You're going
to arrest me. Whatever." He probably could have talked about
what other people were doing that day. I'm guessing he feels
like he gave up a little bit to like he didn't say, right? I
feel like he he he probably thinks he's due a little respect
for that, too. So, but yeah, you can't expect people to sacrifice
more for you than you're willing to for them. And also, don't
expect somebody to it's a professional relationship. Don't expect
somebody to destroy their career for you. I just don't think
you ever expect either of those two things. Even it's like the
morally correct thing to do. I don't think you ever expect that.
If you expect it, just expect also to be
So, we live in this society where it it that just doesn't mean
anything. There's no there's no alliances. There's no real friendships.
And um and I say that as a as someone who is
that's happened to me with other people. You know, they go and
air me out over nothing. You know, you have a difference of opinion,
some doesn't work out, and then people air you out.
And that's so gay. like,
oh, everything you've ever said and done that's embarrassing
or um you know that doesn't sound right or whatever. No, I'm
not going to air it all out like, okay, you're the biggest alive.
Jesus.
Nick doesn't like that the uh the come detective story came out.
Okay, that come detective story has haunted him forever. Okay,
you guys know about the come detective story? That's not a that's
not a flattering one for him. Okay. His uh his roommate and best
friend Jaden McNeil, who was a really close friend of his, okay,
did kind of stab him in the back, broke up with him, you know,
they had a falling out and then Jaden just leaked everything
about their friendship. Okay, Jaden's kind of reminds me of some
people, okay, but
Jaden leaked everything about them. And one of the story that
Jaden
leaked about Nick was when Jaden had a girlfriend over or like
a girl over. He was he was hanging out with this girl on his
couch and Nick showed up like the next day with a black light.
Checking
checking. Okay.
Checking for anything. Which is just weird when you're like 20
years old living with your 20-year-old roommate. You pull out
a black light to look. Okay. Can I find anything here? What's
going on here? All right. the come investigator.
Yeah, it was uh broke up with him. I think there was, you know,
something going on there, but who knows? Who knows? Who knows?
Want to make sure his [__] was okay, man. What's
wrong with that? Want to make sure you're wearing protection.
I shouldn't see anything on this couch, man. I want to make sure
you're wearing protection. That you're staying safe. >> Okay,
you got to stay safe. >> Ben Ruben donated $3. Is it me
or does Nick look like Zack Efron? >> I don't see it, but
interesting. Anyway, Jaden Jaden leaked a ton of [__]
about Nick, right? Anytime I see Jaden McNeel on Twitter, he's
absolutely Well, Jaden's like um
Jaden's in like a Infinity War with uh with the Gropers, right?
I think they've gone after him a lot. A lot. You guys think so?
Zack
New Zack Efron or old Zack Efron? No, I don't see it. I don't
really see it at all.
Maybe this version of Zack Efron, the hair and like the but the
facial features. No, I don't see it.
>> like a hybrid between old and new Zack >> So,
that I do have a tendency.
I'm I'm biased against that because I've been put in that position.
And I heard what Owen said. Owen said that, you know, Alex Jones
was barging into his show and telling him what guest to have,
etc., etc. That the visions are no longer aligned. I get all
that, but it's like,
you know, Jones has taken the slings and arrows and and you know,
look, Owen has had his share of the sacrifice, too. He's been
arrested. He's been charged. He's got skin in the game, too.
Don't get me wrong. But, you know, Alex created Info Wars. Like,
he he's ruined by this stuff. Ruined. The pressure he's under.
At the end of the day, it's his it's his
um nut. And I get that, you know, sometimes it don't work out.
and stuff happens and
you're you're
Again, Nick's making it sound like Owen maybe maybe we have to
go further in the Owen interview.
He's making it sound like Owen leaked something like catastrophic
for Alex, but was it catastrophic that like Alex is a control
freak and wouldn't let Owen be an independent guy and Owen felt
like he's going to get over by collabing with Alex on a school
sh? I feel like those two things are like not really that cataclysmic
to talk about. Maybe the worst thing, maybe the worst thing will
be this that he said Alex like didn't trust him, didn't respect
him, wouldn't let him come back on the show to do like a handshake
and a see each other off, you know, kind of thing like a amicable
breakup. Maybe maybe that's what it is. We'll see. Apparently
Alex has got the call pleasantly, but I really am biased against
the airing out. I only have a statement on that. I really like
Owen, >> dude. The the memes from this, okay, this is not
the only meme, but this is the most prevalent meme. Okay, the
come come detective memes. All right, let's [__]
up. All right. Oh boy.
Oh boy.
There we go. >> I think Owen is a really solid guy. I think
he's very intelligent. He's a great broadcaster. I actually agree
with >> Oh, he goes on to leak that Alex Jones hasn't given
a raise in seven years.
>> Him on the issues way more than Alex, actually. And
I wish him the best. I hope I I would do his show if he asked
me to. I think he's a solid guy if he doesn't hold this against
me. He's always been a good friend to me. I like him a lot and
I goes without saying I love Alex, but I I don't love the airing
out thing. That's just me. But that's me, you know, it's not
really my place cuz what happened is between them, it's their
it's their relationship. It's their company. It's their work.
So, I say that with a great deal of humility. I'm telling you
my bias. I'm telling you when I look at it that the roar shack
test that's what I see. I see how that has happened to me many
times. I had employees, they did this [__] I had
associates, they did this [__] and they all did it
to me. They took turns stabbing them stabbing me in the back
and it didn't feel good. I didn't I thought that was [__]
up. And so
I definitely put myself in Alex Jones shoes. That being said,
it's not my it's not my beat. We we did dirty iszy. We did take
a look at the uh Okay, hold on. I'm cutting him off. >> It's
their life. It's their thing. So, I say that with some humility,
but that's my feelings on it. >> Okay. He said he wasn't
going to talk about it. Gave us six and a half minutes of his
feelings on it. I We did look at it. I think I'm going to take
another look at the tinfoil yam bit, but I will first switch
over. Okay. Last bit on this story before we wrap it. And then
if anybody's got all the uh the bad empanada Hassan Fallout stuff,
I I might have to go put that together and figure it out cuz
uh apparently Hassan has said no more references to bad empanada.
No more references to people who support bad empanada cuz bad
empanada
is
Oh my. No. No way.
Bad bad empanada is transphobic.
What did anyone Did anyone see that? Apparently, that was where
they drew the line. Bad Hassan war was awesome. It was due to
an Iraq veteran socialist at JTO. Okay. Well, I I would check
it out. Asan doing a little Dachshun today. Um yeah, I think
uh he's probably looking at something with a what the PV video
or some [__] I saw Hutch post about that. I don't
know. Did nobody tell Hutch that that that happened? Did Pave
not inform all of those creators that like, hey, we uh we accidentally
[__] up and doxed all of you? Did Did Pavey not let
them know? It seemed like Hutch was like seeing that for the
first time that he's in like FEC filings with his name. And did
nobody ever like give him a heads up like, "Hey, just so you
know, we published your full name and address, buddy." Did they
not do it?
Did they not do it at >> So the bad empa, you just linked
me a bad I'm never watching a bad empanada live video that I've
never seen on ironic postus. I'm literally never ever ever watching
one of these without having watched the whole thing and and confirmed
that I'm not going to pull up a bunch of docs on my stream.
You can't link me these, okay? Don't link me. Bad up and out
of links.
Uh I I could possibly be convinced to watch something, but I
I have to vet the entire thing, right? Like anything with bada.
There could just be Doc's information randomly in the middle
of it. I don't want to do that.
There's no other way to get the context. I'm guarantee you there's
a bunch of other ways to get the context.
I'm telling you, there are there are for sure.
Okay. Anyway, we're we've guys, we're still in the middle of
the InfoWar story. Always short leaving. Uh, listen,
there's a little teaser from Alex Jones's segment. Okay, little
quick teaser. Okay, so this is how we cut in. >> So, I
mean, he took Snake to the next level.
So, Owen Sawyer's dead to me. If if if he goes on air and repents
to Jesus and apologizes for being demonp possessed or whatever
it is he is, then I will forgive him. Owen Troyer, Hillary Clinton,
Barack Obama, all of these people smell like sulfur. They're
all
But he thinks that he would like absorb us as a launch pad and
lie about us to make himself a victim so he could project himself
and launch his own show when he cut and run and didn't even call
me or didn't even say anything or didn't even say, "Hey, what
can I do?" He just cut and run and said, "I'm done with you people."
When Bloomberg and the Onion came in here and ransacked this
place
and we stood up to him and won thanks to your backing and God's
providence. Wait, I forgot that the Onion entered like the bid
to win this. I totally forgot about that. We should go figure
out what actually happened there. When the Onion bought this
place and then they it didn't actually like get turned over >> and
they claimed they won it. Okay. >> The whole time he was
trying to cut and run, but then when he figured out that, oh,
it's still there, he slumped back over and I never even came
to him. Hey, it's good to have you back, man. Glad blah blah
blah. Just Yeah. Okay, sure. Just like people say, "Why was he
swimming around like that?" Because I wasn't going to give him
what he wanted. I knew what he was going to do, but I wanted
to make sure. It's one thing to know what somebody's going to
do, but it's another to wait till they do it. >> Dude,
look at the facial expressions. This guy's like, this guy was
lost. We We like lost something for this guy not going to Hollywood.
Look at the facial expressions as he does this monologue.
because I wasn't going to give him what he wanted. I knew what
he was going to do, but I wanted to make sure. It's one thing
to know what somebody's going to do, but it's another to wait
till they do it. And he did it worse than I thought. So Owen
thinks this new franchise is going to be talking crap about me.
He thinks his new franchise is going to be running down this
fabled operation, this incredible crew and our supporters that
are the InfoWar. Well, guess what, buddy?
You can up a rope. No matter what happens to this office or the
name Info Wars, we're going to go on forever. Thanks to the listeners
and the viewers. God bless you all. God bless you. All right.
I'm behind Alex again. Okay.
Up a rope. Dude,
Alex is a legend because or national treasure because he didn't
go to Hollywood. Well, he kind of did go to Hollywood. He's been
in some movies, but he is uh Dude, that was crazy. Just that
was a that was a crazy monologue. All right, we get the full
segment from Alex here. Give me a second. Get the full segment.
We're going to watch this and then we'll uh we'll see what's
up next. There's a couple different things going on. >> We
got 39 minutes on Owen Shroyer here. I don't know if we're going
to do the whole thing. We'll see. We'll see. Seemed like the
whole segment might be worth watching. All right. Give me a second.
I'm going to use the bathroom, get some water,
and I will be right back. Okay. Be right back. Let's I'm I'm
psyched. Okay. I'm psyched. I didn't
Alex Jones is like uh he's like the guy. Okay. He's like, "God,
forgive me for what I must do." Okay, he's Jean Wick,
you know, taking the sledgehammer out and breaking his vault
open of all of his guns. He's like, "I got to take this guy out.
God, forgive me. I've got to take I've got to take Owen out now."
Okay. The performative relig relig
religiosity that these people put on all the time feels almost
satirical. I don't think Alex was this performatively
like grandiose in his relig religiosity before. I think that's
something in the last like two, three years. He'd talk about
demons and stuff, but he wouldn't quite be this performative,
I don't think. Or at least I didn't recall it. It seems like
the last what, three, four years, it's become more. Yeah. Replace
every D roll with Alex Jones.
>> see what's up here. >> One of the >> Give
me one second. >> Most despicable things there is. >> Oh
god. and particularly betrayal that is carefully crafted and
that is premeditated. To know that someone who acts like they're
your friend is plotting and scheming and manipulating and to
just disregard it because you're a loyal person. And then to
see that individual betray just you but the crew and the idea
of what we are and how embattled we are
and to try to cast us as the villains and he as the hero and
the victim. I will not put up with it. It is the holy grail out
there to be
because when you really are censored, people want to stri effect
find out what's been censored.
And I've been really censored.
I've been really attacked and so is Infowars, but I've never
accused people of censoring or oppressing me who didn't do it.
And we had another talk show host
about 6 years ago post on Twitter that we were censoring him.
He didn't say what. I came into him and I said, "What did we
ever censor? What do we ever do?" He said, "I'm not talking to
you about it. You know, you're censoring me." I said, "How?"
I said, "Listen, do it again. You're fired." And about a year
later, they were uploading his morning show and this happens,
you know, every once in a while. And only the first hour went
up and he flipped out and went online and said that he was being
censored by us. And I called him up and he started yelling at
me. Don't
>> Okay, I'm back. Wait, am I back? I'm not quite back.
Guys, can we get uh can we get some of the bad empata stuff?
I'm sorry. like uh post in the stream chat channel or if if anybody
knows that story, if anybody's seen it, I would love to check
that out. I'm just trying to find that. I would I would like
to cover that after this if anybody's looking into that stuff.
Okay. I don't know if anyone's looking around at it, but I I
want to check out Bad Pod versus Han. That whole breakdown. All
right. It's not kosher drama. It's got doc's everywhere. Well,
I mean, whatever Hassan's watching on Twitch, we'll watch on
here, and I'll try to skip past it where I can. Okay.
We'll see. I know you're a moral f about Well, you didn't say
f, but about doc's. Um,
can we not just We can't figure out where that stuff is. All
right. Well, we'll see. We'll see. Censored.
And I've been really censored.
I've been really attacked and so is info. >> Go back a
little bit. Okay. >> But I've never accused people of censoring
or oppressing me who didn't do it. And we had another talk show
host
about 6 years ago post on Twitter that we were censoring him.
He didn't say what. I came into him and I said, "What?" And about
a year later, they were the show. And this happens, you know,
every once in a while. And only >> Sorry, I uh Yeah, I
had to reconnect my headphones there. Give me >> first
hour went up and he flipped out and went online and said that
he was being censored by us and I called him up and he started
yelling at me. Don't you give me that? You and I and I said the
all the time we upload stuff to everywhere they'll upload it.
We don't even know. What were you talking about? He was bashing
Trump.
And I said that's it. You're fired, man. >> Why does he
name this guy? >> Not because of what he was saying about
topics, but because he was saying we were censoring.
So I And that was David Knight. So I've got a real problem with
this. And I took the high road on that because I wasn't very
close to David
>> Okay, never mind. and he was kind of the grumpy old
man and was just frustrated that his show wasn't as popular as
mine and and I promoted it and just had a chip on his shoulder
and I mean I did stuff like you give him hundreds of thousands
of dollars when he had a heart attack and you know hire both
his sons and you know kiss his ass and and the more I was nice
to him the more he just got angry and hateful and then he's gone
out since then and disgra >> All right, hit me with a Hassanabi
time stamp. Okay, hit me with that. I'm very excited for this.
Sorry to prove you the next content piece while we're doing this
one. >> Himself and said that just I I flat out censored
him with Alex for now. >> Oh, really? Show the proof. Not
true. >> I mean, this is ridiculous. Okay,
so Owen Shroyer has now done this and and and the way he did
it is particularly deceptive. Like he thinks I'm stupid. Um got
a very uh aggressive phone call from him with him yesterday and
then he ran off and and did his, you know, publicity stunt at
my expense. the cruise expense at the at this institution's expense.
And I mean just just lie after life after lie. I mean I've got
and we're checking with lawyers right now, but I've got his tax,
you know, filings. I've got what he's paid. I I've got everything
here. Said he hadn't had a raise since 2018.
Listen, if there's one thing we know about Alex, he has the documents.
Okay. He has the documents. Owen up. Also, why the would you
need his tax forms? Why couldn't you just You're his employer.
Wouldn't you have like payubs?
Wouldn't you just show payubs?
>> Since 2018, he's had multiple raises of $80,000
on top of what he was paid before and huge bonuses. Have them
all right here. That's just one example
who these people think they are. So, I didn't put him in prison
on J6. We raised the money for him to fight it. I didn't do any
of these things. And to watch the way and I couldn't watch the
whole 5 hours. cuz I wasn't even going to watch until people
kept sending me clips and my phone was blowing up and all these
text messages and is this true? Is that true? And I
>> did Owen really not just do a full show? I would have
assumed Owen did a full show on top of like 30 to 60 minutes
of talking about Alex. They really do 5 hours of talking about
getting fired. That's a lot. >> Watching it and notice
it's why I'm leaving InfoWars, not I quit or I was fired leaving
Nebulous. But just get him on the screen. I can't look at him.
And he's like, "Oh, I understand why he didn't want me to talk
bad about Trump. up his access cut off. That's why I've got to
go. Oh, I understand the things I was doing were really causing
the problem. No, they weren't. I never told him you ought to
do this or that. I said, "Hey, you should you can attack Trump
all you want, but hey, we also need to stay on top of the Democrats
here." I said that on air. I never even said that to him in person.
I said on air. That's what talk show hosts do. I started out
on talk radio. Other shows on the same station. The morning show
talks about the afternoon show and they disagree and agree and
they and they have debates. That that's normal. We're not in
a cult here. I'm not censoring somebody because I say I'm not
throwing the baby out with the bath water. I have Nick Fuentes
on who says he's totally done with Trump and I say, "You're making
good points. I can see why you say it, but I disagree on this,
this, and that." And Nick doesn't go, "Oh my god, you're censoring
me because you disagree with me." That's not what that is.
And I talked to Nick this morning and he obviously thinks that
before I even told him what went on that, you know, Owen handled
it completely wrong. But it it was as I started this morning,
I I didn't do my workout cuz I was busy. And I decided, okay,
I'm going to go ahead and watch these clips. And I sat there
and and what made me really mad was he was acting all sad and
hurt and oh, you know, this happened and well,
it was like innuendo
for hours and hours and at the end, oh, Alex never censored me.
But he stood over my shoulder. Yeah. like what once a month come
in to give you something which when he was hired was part of
the thing. That's why there's microphones in the control rooms.
I want everybody to get on air. Hey, breaking news. I'll come
in and hand them a did you see this on Fox? This just happened.
I will say that if that's like a part of the dynamic that seems
like a helpful like that's one of the few things you get of having
everybody in the same studio, right? Like Alex coming in. I can
see that being a really good content piece, right? Alex like
breaks in. Owen, Owen, you'll never believe it. Owen, you'll
never believe what just happened. Look at this. Look at this.
Look at this document. Look at this. Cover this. Right. I think
that I can see that being like a massive draw for people. They'd
love when Alex like breaks in and it's like, "You have to see
this. This is incredibly important. Get it on the
Tell Owen doesn't mean have him on. He was mad. He told the crew.
Then I'll have a guest on and say, "Hey, you're here. You're
a huge guest." Nick Foto as an example or or whoever. Uh
Roger Stone, whoever it is. Hey, you know, did they book you?
Hey, call Owen, see if he wants him on.
Owen told the crew that that was me controlling a show, just
helping a newsroom. Hey, you want to go on another show? Let's
see if they can have a slot for you. That's what he's got. That's
what David Knight had because they they they need to be censored.
They need me to be the villain. Oh my gosh. One time they only
uploaded the first hour of his show instead of three. And so
the the evil people that just uploaded everywhere and 99% of
the time get it right, they made a mistake. Finally, Alex Jones
censored me. Finally. Oh, finally. It's so good. It's so I'm
a victim.
Dude, Owen up so badly. I'm sorry.
I watched like 15 minutes of Owen because it was like kind of
boring. Dude, this guy's just This guy's the greatest showman.
Okay, he is the greatest showman. And I listen, Alex could be
Oh, hi.
Alex could be completely in the wrong here and I'd still probably
believe him because he's just that good a showman. Okay. He's
impressive. What's up, Jerry? How's it >> Good. I heard
we were going to watch us
>> Uh, yeah, in a little bit after we finish watching Alex
Jones.
>> Everybody's favorite.
All right. Okay. Cool.
Isn't Alex Jones awesome? Don't we love Alex Jones? >> I'm
the best. >> Yeah, I like when he's uh red.
>> Okay. Well, that's all the time. >> He's bad.
See, he was evil. I was good. And that's why people that bash
me and I've talked about this a lot on air. You see it all the
time. I'll have a guest on and we go to break and that they post
it and go, "Look, when they talked about this subject, he went
to break."
And they don't show that coming out of break, we always come
back to it. Or that the brakes have been set for 27 years at
the exact same time. got one coming up in 14 minutes 20 seconds.
Set your watch by it. It's an atomic clock. They censor by not
showing you what they said after and then invert it and say I
censored that. That's what other people do cuz this is the whole
thing to manufacture censorship.
>> Uh these guys have discovered the the concept of clip
chimping and they're calling it censorship. It's I love it. I
love it. >> And so you can have a Strizzand effect. Oh,
there was bad stuff going on. you know, I had to go cuz you know
this and that and I mean like we're not human. That's very sociopathic.
We're not human. And to boost yourself so you can get
a million live streamers watching. Here it is right here. >> You
print out >> couldn't do that. >> He printed out
a tweet. That's what he does. Okay. That's what that's the man's
Let's not call it question. Okay. A million live stream viewers
>> on regular news topics. Though Owens done some great
stuff and done great works. I hired him. No, no, no. But for
whatever reason, if I can just get that hit again, I'll just
come out and attack Alex Jones and play victim and act sad the
whole time. And it's not true.
So Owen, tell us again you hadn't had a raise since 2018.
>> Can't delete it if he prints it. You know what? I can't
find a flaw in this logic. Can't find a flaw in Alex's logic.
Alex won. >> Is $80,000 increase in three different raises?
Is that a
8,000 on top of what you're getting paid? Tell people what you
are paid. You got the clips. How about telling people How about
tell people about the bonuses or the Hellcat I gave you just
as a friend. Here, have my Hellcat.
No way. Did Alex give a >> hand Hellcat?
>> That's That's Can you even gift a Hellcat? Wouldn't
the insurance be insane if you're like not making enough money?
Wouldn't that be crazy to try to own a Hellcat >> like
when you're just making regular person money?
That's like when you win like a really fancy car on one of those
TV shows. Like you go to win the car and then you have to pay
the tax for it and you're like >> Some states tax game
show winnings. That should be illegal. Okay. That should be const
your game show winning should be constitutionally proh protected.
Okay. >> You like win [__] wheel fortune without
the taxes. >> Yeah. You win like wheel of fortune, you
can't even afford to keep the car. That's crazy. That would suck.
The price is right. You win like a camper like a Winnebago and
a trip and it's just like they're like yeah pick one. You actually
only get one. You have to sell the other. Okay. It's [__]
up.
That would be best if they paid the taxes. Oprah screwed all
screwed all those people. That's why Oprah's a cut. Did Oprah
Oprah really did that? Like Oprah's got so much money she would
fix that. >> No. No. That's why that was like a a whole
thing, right? People I think people complained on Facebook or
>> I never heard about that. That's crazy. She gave them
cars and they couldn't afford the taxes. Well,
>> Oh, right. Dude, remember when people used to meme Oprah's
show? God, I'm old.
I just remember that out of nowhere. That's like one of the oldest
memes on the internet.
>> I will always remember. What is his name? Tom the short
one.
>> Oh, Tom Cruz. >> Mission Impossible. Yeah. Yeah.
Tom Cruz is just jumping on the couch. I love her. Like what
was he talking about?
>> Manic episode. Oh boy. He's talking about what was it?
His beard, right? Katie uh Katie. >> Yeah, she's definitely
his beard. Katie Holmes. Yeah. >> Yeah, that man is gay.
That man is gay as sin. Okay. It's It's crazy. Okay, I got to
I got to focus up. I Okay, speaking of great actors. Okay, Alex
Jones, Betrayed. He's about to show us Owen Shroyer's tax
filings, I guess, for the past couple years. I don't know. >> It
was worth about $60,000 on game. It was $85,000 when I bought
it. Oh, yeah. Tell me on about how bad I am again. So, if somebody
will lie about people he said was his friend for 10 years like
that and so nakedly. That's a really nice person. And and and
so let me tell you what happened yesterday. I'll get to all the
other newses coming up. Owen, last Thursday, I'm all stressed
out. My dad's had open heart surgery. It went well. I'm driving
back up to Temple to see him, you know, driving back and forth.
You came down on Thursday to do the show in the morning. Drove
up here like 5:00 a.m. do my show, get in the car, leave. And
Kyle Sarapin starts texting me saying, "Hey, I just got sued
by Cashell's girlfriend." Plus, he found a secret J6 database
secretly persist and that I go, "Well, that's huge." I said,
"Well, uh, can you go on Owen show if if you've got a slot?"
He said, "Yeah, when?" He said, "430."
So I call up
Rob Aguero who's the producer at that time and I say, "Hey, CF
Owen wants him on. He's got a slot. He can come on anytime after
4:30."
And then uh Rob calls back and he says, "Well, what's the topics?"
And I said, "Well, just call Sarapin." But and and I said, "I'll
send a voice memo to Owen."
So Owen during the break listens to it and says, "That's it.
I'm leaving."
And says, "I'm controlling his show."
in a newsroom saying, "Hey, this is a big thing. Uh, I can't
do it because, you know, I stay up here at night and do reports.
I'd have done it. Here's this thing, you know, our team." And
that's been like that ever since he was here before he was here.
I mean, the guys are in there grabbing articles and videos and
and and I'll, you know, when no one shows start, I run over there
with stuff that I think is important. Hey, do you already have
this? I think this is pretty big. You know, about this. That's
what goes on in newspapers and TV stations and radio stations.
You know, it's like having a pig skin in a football game or a
baseball in a baseball game or or or lights for a nighttime game
or >> I'll be honest, this is uh this is getting way out
there. >> Hot dogs and and Coca-Cola being sold. >> What
is he talking about? >> He's like he's he's off on a tangent,
okay? He's entertaining. >> In the world of victimhood,
>> we're going >> in the world of victimhood. That
is like absolute total censorship
to give people information. But that's how he's then vain.
He was standing over me. You know, actually if we did our job
better, I I would be doing that every day, not bringing them
something once a week. Hey, in here on the computer, I just grabbed
it off Fox off the satellite. Uh hey, we have raw feed. He still
uses all of like the old words for all of the things, right?
Like >> grabbed it off the satellite. >> We grabbed
it off the satellite. We grab we got all the live feeds. We grab
it off the satellite. >> It's too off satellites. Hey,
look at this raw feed. Come get this. >> You have a signal.
>> That's so bad. That's That's bad, isn't it? Like I'm
running around at big TV screens with satellite feeds and saying,
"Look at this. Look at that." I mean, that is just horrible.
I sit in the coffee room that's got satellite feeds and eat my
lunch at 3:00 and then I sit there and text the crew, "Hey, this
is looks interesting. That looks interesting." Man, I want to
apologize right now. I mean, you're talking nasty evil, okay?
Being a news hound, I mean, I want to apologize actually to Owen
for that. But that's the type of sophistry where you you you
go, "Oh, he would hang over me. He would try to control the show.
He would whatever." Total lie. >> What does sophistry mean
here? >> What is sophistry like? >> He's just lying.
>> Making it like Yeah. totally like incorrect point. You
sound like you're right, but you're making a totally incorrect
point, right? You just argue something to argue with. Not sure.
>> I I think Hold on. Let me look up >> like saying
that he's standing over me. Like he's not lying, but he's just
uh
>> arguments especially with the intention of deceiving.
Yeah. Yeah. So he's just >> Okay. Yeah. >> Yeah.
He's uh he's lying. He's lying then as all the articles come
out and Jones uh censored
Shroyer on Trump criticism and Israel. So, let's let's see if
Schroyer comes out and apologizes for Oh, no. He's going to say,
"I didn't really exactly say that." No, no, you couched each
statement perfectly thought out
and and looking down at your notes to be able to lie about us
and try to hurt this organization for your benefit so you could
be a hero. You are a snake.
You are a rat.
You are a fraud.
You are a backstabber. You are a handbiter.
You are a disgrace. And let me say something else about you.
>> You're a snob.
>> Even before he went to prison for 4 months and we did
the crowdfunding raise. F. >> That's such a cheap shot.
What the Even before he went to prison for 4 months. This guy's
a criminal by the way for going to Jens >> to do coverage
for your news station. >> He stopped talking to the crew
very much and didn't have a good attitude. Was pissed off all
the time. And then it got to where he wouldn't he'd show up right
before the show, wouldn't even talk to the crew. He'd he'd walk
by me and say something like, you know, start laughing at me
like,
I'm not in junior high, so it didn't hurt me at that level. It
hurt me that he was just like,
>> "Hold on." >> No, it it hurt him. That hurt so
much. >> Brings it up. Yeah. I walk by and they just laugh
at me. >> Hold on. >> He would talk to crew. He he'd
walk by me and say something like, you know,
sort of laughing at me like I'm not in junior high, so it didn't
hurt me at that level. It hurt me that he was just like, "Yeah,
I Oh, and we can go further." When The Onion back by Bloomberg
did the fraudulent auction and got caught in all of that back
in
>> He literally he literally just remembers this guy like
smirking at him. He like remembered that for like a year to just
be like this piece of [__] No, more than a year.
Wait, it was Jan 6. This must be like three, four years, right?
He's been just remembering this and seething about it. That's
crazy. >> Oh, yeah. But we And you know it's real cuz we've
all had a moment like this. Like I hate that laugh. I know she
laughing at me. That [__] And that laugh just lives
in your head. Rentree. >> Yeah. And And then you tell people
you tell somebody about it and then you realize that you're like
being a little too accurate with how you're describing it. You're
like, not that it upsets me. Not that it like not that I was
mad about it or anything. Not that >> like I'm not in junior
high. It doesn't hurt my feelings when somebody laughs at >> Didn't
get to me. >> November 13th and I said, "We're not leaving.
This is a fraud. I'm fing emergency motion. The judge found it
to be a fraud."
Had a two-day hearing on all that. Owen just left and just called
the producer and said, "I'm done. I quit." Even though we have
a backup studio. I told everybody, "Hey, it's going to be fine.
We have new backers. All this stuff we can shut down." He's like,
"I'm gone." Starts announcing, "Is this the time?" because shutting
down. He thinks announced his new network and funding and all
this stuff. And then
we're back the next day and Owen just shows back up and does
his show
and walks in and just looks I mean looks at me with hatred and
like slinks in there
cuz he really wanted me to fire him so he could be a victim.
And I and I I confided just a few of the producers I said he
wants to be a victim. I said, "I'm going to have love and say
prayers for him and he gets better. It'll be really nice to him.
Give him extra bonuses. Maybe he'll pull out of it. I try to
talk to him. He's never wanted to talk to me." And I said, "Uh,
but I said he'll he's going to me in the back. He's he's he's
he's a new person." And I don't know if it's his personal life.
I I don't this time on the inside changed >> Know if it's
stuff he's smoking. >> Sound weird. This guy was nice to
freeze frame. The stuff he's smoking. the stuff he's smoking.
>> Who gives somebody raises if they think that they're
trying to be a victim? He walked in, he was so angry at me. I
could tell he wanted to be a victim. So, I gave him a bunch of
raises. What? >> And prayed for him. Yeah. I don't know.
It seems Listen, there's one thing I know Alex Jones for. It's
he he doesn't he doesn't overmbellish anything. Okay? I'm pretty
sure this would have happened. All right? Never heard of him
doing that. >> But I've seen a lot of people get paranoid.
you know, the smoke pot and go nuts.
But I mean, I can just tell you this right now that that I'm
not here to be shed on or stabbed in the back. This crew isn't
your punching bag and we did nothing to you but be loyal and
your little 5hour extravaganza
of little puppy dog that doesn't know why. And he just wanted
to come back and shake my hand and be nice. And then I kind of
censored him and said, "No, you don't need to host your show.
You want to hear what he said in the phone call to me. I didn't
record it. I was in the pool with my 8-year-old daughter
playing with her Barbie dolls at whatever it was 4:00 yesterday.
You know, a rare day. I actually only came in and worked the
office about 4 hours. So, I I go back. She's literally, you know,
calling me, "Daddy, you're supposed to be home. You said to be
home at 10:00. I want to play in the yard." So, I'm sitting there
about 4:00 bobbing around and I get a text message.
Hey, uh, I'll see you at 10:00 a.m. tomorrow. Cuz remember, I
called him Thursday when he just got up and left. I said, "Hey,
what's wrong?"
And he's like, "Monday." I mean, cuz he's he's the commander.
And I and so I asked him a few texts later. I said, "Hey, can
we talk now?" ignores me. So, Monday rolls around. Talk 10:00
a.m. tomorrow. I got the text right here. And I'm like, "Uh,
that's kind of late. maybe 9:30, whichever. I said, "How about
we just talk right now?" I go, "It's pretty clear you're about
to quit." He go, "You really want to do this right now?" I said,
"Yeah." So, he calls up and uh while I'm calling him, he calls
me. So, I pick it up. Sorry, this just caught me off guard. I
It's not It's not relevant to anything. He just coughs without
even a remote twitch towards his face with his hand. >> ignores
me. So, Monday rolls around. Talk 10 a.m. tomorrow. >> Just
watch this. >> I got the catch right here. And I'm like,
"Oh, that's kind of late. maybe 9:30, whichever. I said, "How
about we just talk right now?" Cuz I go, "It's pretty clear you're
about to quit." He go, "You really want to do this right now?"
I said, "Yeah." So he calls up and >> he just coughs. There's
no no moving the hand up at all.
>> It also looked like it was about to be a sneeze. So
that's even crazier if he wasn't going to cover his mouth
>> just directly into the microphone. Yeah. I don't I don't
know.
>> While I'm calling him, he calls me. So, I pick it up
and
he starts talking to me like he's literally a pimp and I am a
crack. He's like, "Here, >> I have to hear how this could
possibly go for this to make sense. We heard this clip earlier,
but Jesus Christ, >> here's how it's going to be. I'm leaving
and blah blah blah. What's the problem? What's the thing?" Well,
what can we do? I mean, you I I don't understand. He's like,
"Well, it's just gone on too long and whatever." But I'll tell
you this. If you're really desperate, if you're really desperate,
you can pay me more money, but I'll tell you this. I'm going
to promote my new show on Infowars.
And I went, which again, I'm not even against having a show.
He was nice. I was just like, it was just kind of like I was
like, well, yeah. I said, you know, in the bankruptcy stuff,
I can't really give you a raise. But I said, that's okay, Owen.
He goes, well, you know what? You know, as a favor for you, I'll
come in and do a week. And I'm like, no, that's that that's okay,
Owen. Yeah, I'm not that's fine. I I wish you well. And and I
hung up and literally got a tear in my eye cuz he was talking
to me with just like just like a like Patrick Baitman or something.
And so I go back and get in the pool and you know, keep playing.
>> I'm going to
everyone in chat when I ask who's Patrick Baitman chat pretend
like you don't know. >> No, I'll let them fill you in.
I don't know who that is. Wait, who is Patrick Baitman? I haven't
heard of this guy. >> Yeah. Who's Who's Patrick Baitman?
Who's that? Who's that? Who? I don't. That's right. I think I
know who Spacey is. >> Does she?
>> House of Cards guy. No. Uncultured. Dirty dancing. Yeah,
that's Patrick Spacey. I just threw my bottle. Just play the
clip. They're saying weird. It's happening. >> Six. Okay,
bro. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. It's the uh protagonist anti-hero
from American Psychos, the guy Patrick Baitman. Americans. >> I
never saw it. >> Okay. Well, I think I I think I've already
reacted to this in private, this information before, so it's
not hitting me that that hard this time. >> There's a movie
whatever's in the >> My assess
Wait, anti-hero is like an appropriate term, isn't it? Yeah,
you've we've talked about it. Is it is anti-hero not what it
like evil?
Maybe. I guess there's no there's no hero part. He's just like
the villain, but it's a villain piece. I guess he's the protagonist,
right? Maybe anti-hero is a word to use for it. My bad. My bad.
>> So then he races out and goes on air and it's like,
you know, I'm just leaving because, you know, I know I can't
talk about Trump and you know, I know it hurts Jones's access
and you know, he really all inuendo didn't he didn't have the
guts to just tell the pure lie that I told him to do stuff, which
I didn't, and a bunch of other stuff. I haven't even watched
half of it. It's just so painful to watch. He's sitting there
manipulating and wriggling around like a snake trying to make
it as bad as he can, but skate skate the edge so he can say,
"I never did that." Cuz he he's got the whole crew knows it's
not true. He's got the other host that know it's not true. So
he wants to pull a knight. I mean, Harrison Smith says whatever
he wants. I walked in this morning, I said, "Have I ever told
you not to say something?" He goes, "No, it's actually I'm surprised
you haven't. I'm I'm kind out of control." I go, "I'm not like
you're dude." Your boss walks in. Have I ever have I ever done
anything wrong in the workplace? Have I ever broken our employee
handbook before? Your boss walks in. He's like, "Uh, no, sir.
No, you've never done anything wrong in your entire life." See,
I'm innocent. I don't know. I don't know if that's the way it
works, Alex. Okay, that's a little crazy.
I believe Alex I do believe Alex doesn't like censor people.
I'm guessing he doesn't love Owen's, you know, anti-semitism.
Probably not a fan. Owen's opinions on Israel. >> Good
guy. Just say whatever you want. So, and I've got all the producers
and all the people I've said on air. I think Owens too blackpilled
as an example and that we all should be more positive. That's
my opinion. It's not an attack. It's a discussion. So, he then
runs on air and is like, I just wanted to come back for a week
and shake his hand and thank him. But he he didn't he doesn't
want to be my friend. Anyway, let me tell you how it is. I mean,
literally. Yeah, I know. It's all over. You can't get me back.
I tell you though, if you're really desperate. And he said that
and I went, "Excuse me?" There was more. And he goes, "Well,
I mean, if if you want to do something really desperate." And
he was really getting off on it. And I'm like going, "This is
an evil son of a [__] man. Wow. I had a snake around
here. I had no idea." And I literally started getting tears in
my eyes cuz he was burning down like an old >> I can see
it. He's like painting the picture. Okay. He's painting the >> Burns
up in like 2 minutes. He's burning down. I'm just like, "Oh,
and I got to go, man." And I literally stumbled in the pool and
I was just like >> just that single tear rolled down his
round down his cheek. Okay. And he just had to get in the pool.
He was stunned. He was stunned. Owen Owen is evil. Owen is evil.
I can't I can't believe it. I can't believe it. And I was like,
I'm going to take the high road. I called the crew. I said, let's
be nice. Let's be sweet. And then I started seeing the clips.
And Owens, man, you're a piece of crap, brother. All right. And
and and if I was anybody, I wouldn't turn my back on Owenser.
So, I mean, he took Snake to the next level.
So, Owen Schroyer's dead to me. If if if he goes on air and repents
to Jesus and apologizes for being demonp possessed or whatever
it is he is, then I will forgive him. But he thinks that he would
like absorb us as a launchpad and lie about us to make himself
a victim so he could project himself and launch his own show
when he cut and run and didn't even call me or didn't even say
anything or didn't even say, "Hey, what can I do?" He just cut
and run and said, "I'm done with you people." when Bloomberg
and the Onion came in here and ransacked this place
and we stood up to him and won thanks to your backing and God's
providence
and the whole time he was trying to cut and run. But then when
he figured out >> cuz Bloomberg almost sounds like blooming
and then the onion. So I'm thinking about like the blooming onion,
>> you know that fried onion that they sell at Long John's
>> or is it Outback sick house? I don't know what it is.
>> I think it's I think it's Outback. We didn't we don't
have those in Canada. I've never seen an outback steakhouse before.
So, unfortunately, I don't know. >> Good here. >> I
remember the only thing I know about blooming onions. Okay. >> Popeyes
here. >> I remember. Was there not a soda popping thing?
Did you not have to blend the blooming onion to drink it? >> Is
that a thing? I remember something insanely disgusting from Sodapoppin
stream that I recall.
>> You guys know what I'm talking about, >> I know
that >> when he lost that bet. There's got to be some soda
popping fans in here who could tell me about it. There's no way
we don't have any of the soda popping fans who are normally here.
Where's Zezy? Zezy would know this for sure. Hold on. Soda popping
blooming onion.
>> Dude, Canadian fast food is so foul. I don't know what
they do. They like take they take the American fast food and
they're like, "Oh, do you do this with a lot of sauce? We're
just going to put powder on it. We're going to give you powder
sauce." Yes. And then they put like moldy cheese on everything
and call it poutine. >> Wait, wait. Yeah, it's not moldy
cheese. It's cheese curds. But hold on, guys. >> Mold something,
>> guys. Okay.
What am I thinking about? Somebody, if you've watched Sodapop
and he he like blended something, I'm positive it's a bloom and
onion. I'm positive I've seen this. Nobody's nobody's answering
this right now. You going to stand up for your country? I wasn't
listening. I'm looking for the soda popping clip cuz it haunts
me to this day and I cannot find a video of it. Am I not spelling
soda popping correctly? >> S. How can I not find it? >> A
p o p p p p p p i n. >> Yes, it's a whole onion. Something
called sometimes called an onion blossom. Wait, no, no, no, no,
dude. Somebody is Nobody can find this.
>> Moody Morgan, you know who Sodapoppin is? Stop it. He's
the guy who looks like Lewig, but obviously has like the soul
of Asmin Gold. Okay, I'm gonna I'm gonna have to shut down the
Discord. Okay, the general chat's getting shut down until somebody
tells me what this was. We go we're going to go uh general chats
off for everybody until somebody explains to me. Okay. >> What
did the Discord do?
>> Uh clip of soda popping drinking a blended shake that
I think is a blooming onion from Outback
Steakhouse.
need immediately.
Chat stopped until clip received. Okay, I need that clip. This
maybe this. Hold on. Maybe NeoC has saved the Discord. It's possible
NeoC has saved the Discord, but I need this clip stat. >> Got
it. I have a blender, too. >> Yeah, this is it.
>> Yeah, this is it. >> The Discord. >> Yeah,
you'll be able to hear it. >> This is it. The Discord has
been saved. >> The Diablo >> Neosc had you guys immediately.
That's crazy. is hot. >> Let's go.
>> Oh my god. That's an entire tub of it. >> It'll
be liquid. Perfect.
>> Don't I do not want you to
>> Oh, wait. Did I even shut the general chat off? >> Oh,
yeah. I did.
>> We're back. We're back.
>> All right. You're permitted to cut it
>> a drink of your choice. >> And here are the Republican
tacos.
>> Amen, brother. So he gets this he gets this whole order
whatever this is >> and he puts it in a blender. Okay.
>> It's not a bloom and onion. I misunderstood what it
was. Okay. I
>> Might as well be
>> that looks disgusting before you.
>> It does look disgusting before he blanco
hot dogs and tacos. Brother
>> I don't I've never used a blender before. I don't know.
Well, we're going to learn. >> This might be worse than
the Mr.
>> Oh, this is
I'm going to say this is >> Does he not know about a lid?
>> Put the lid on. Put the lid on.
>> Stop. Stop.
>> Okay, hold on. >> Are you stupid? >> I hope
you guys are ready for this. This is far more This is maybe one
of the most disgusting things I've ever seen. Okay, so he's like
adding stuff in
>> Oh, right. He doesn't have enough liquid, right? They
were worried he didn't have enough liquid, so he goes and grabs
a seven up >> warm
chances. Enjoy this.
>> Not even a Sprite.
>> That's gross. >> Seven up. >> I can't believe
you.
>> Gets the lid on.
>> More blended.
>> Okay, he blends. He blends.
Is >> that a martini glass? Mash up the onion with his
hand.
So glad I have two monitors. Chance's gag is warranted and Komodo's
>> This is This is what it took to make it on Twitch back
in the day. Okay, guys. >> If Asmin was in that room, Asmin
would not have a single gag reflex to that.
>> Oh, it's chunky. >> What the [__]
is that?
>> It looks so bad. It looks so bad.
That's enough.
>> He didn't He didn't blend it enough. He didn't blend
it enough.
>> Look at the martini glass. Why did you get a martini
glass?
>> Wait, wait, Chance.
>> How much for you to do this when you go on camera? >> Smell
like it smells. >> I won't. I won't. His eyes are >> I'm
never going to do like this. Look at >> his eyes. >> No.
Everyone has a price.
Uh, like
50k.
Unironically, like 50k. I might do it for cheaper, but I need
like 50k to commit to it now. >> To have like the dread
of knowing that I could get paid that >> I'd do it for
cheaper, but I'd need to be in like a mood or something. You'd
have like a couple drinks or some [__] I don't know.
>> Someone said $1,000. Someone said hundred. Someone said
100.
>> I would not do it for $1,000. I would not do it for
$1,000. I promise you. I can say right now that I've done stuff
for $1,000 on stream before. I've gotten 200 subs for subs on
stream. Uh, no. I'm I would No, no, no. >> What have you
done for $1,000?
>> Um, don't want to talk about it.
>> Okay. It's it it just
god damn it. >> Wait, can I can I see this really quick?
I have nothing. >> Oh, right. He had a whole bet with another
guy who was doing the same thing. Okay. >> See this? Can
I see this really quick? I have not seen it yet. What you're
doing? >> This is where the bloom and onion comes >> You
want to see this?
>> Bloom and onion, man.
>> He was right. Redeemed
>> in there. >> And you >> This guy actually
does it with his magic bullet though.
>> He blends it up. Water first.
>> Bottoms up, guys.
>> I'll be honest. I forget who this is. I think they [__]
something up in a WoW raid and they had to do this. I think >> the
clip of his. >> All right, K, you can go first. >> Oh
my god. Maybe that would fix Pirate
>> He had to drink this every time he >> My hands
are shaking.
>> Enough talk.
>> Don't think about it. Just go. Just go. >> If
you're going to vomit, >> somebody count me down.
>> 3 2 1 go. 3 2 1 go. >> Three, two, one, go. >> Oh,
he's doing it. >> Oh my god.
>> You can do it. You can do it.
>> you did it. You did. Yeah.
>> That guy likes his. Okay.
>> Are you saying that he's fat? >> Uh, no. I'm saying
it cuz I don't know. That guy That guy went back for seconds
for a second.
>> I don't understand.
>> Hold on.
Oh, hold on. We'll check that out after. We got to watch Soda.
Okay, real quick. We got to watch Soda. >> That's so funky.
Uh Todd Bronson in chat says uh not even $1,000 to drink a blooming
onion, but $50 to rate Wes's >> his bridge. Don't misread
that. His damage. Okay.
>> I intentionally decide to read it the way that I did.
>> Um yeah. Uh this is far more foul than looking at Wes's
uh mutilated. Okay. This is far more foul. Just putting something
in your body. That's gross.
God doesn't make mistakes. Okay?
>> Man, relended. >> God don't make no junk. Okay?
God don't make no junk.
>> Why did you just get racist? >> What do you mean
racist? That's a southern accent. That's like white trash. Can't
be racist against my own >> Okay, buddy.
>> That looks like hamburger helper. >> Listen, Chance,
>> it's food, man. Eat it. You can make it more smooth
if you want. It'll probably be better if you do it that way.
>> I will allow you one sip. I'll let you do one sip first
just to taste the heat. Okay. Because I don't want you to chug
something that might be >> I'm gonna take a small sip to
taste it just to see like a little I'm just going to lick it.
>> He's going to quit after you in your >> Let's
do some smoothie weeding. >> He doesn't He like inhaled
the smell and he's already gagging.
>> Is this almost over? I bet you there are people who
are trying to eat their food.
>> No, it's not almost over. So hot.
>> It's hot. Seven up.
>> Got to blend more. Seven up.
>> Your elbow.
>> Won't gag if you >> He's just smelling it from
across the >> It won't It won't happen again. I'm so >> We're
We're right there, guys. We're right there. >> Like he's
apologizing to him. >> Wait, hold on. Wait a second. Before
you do this, we need a
We need a
Okay. Okay. All right. He's gonna go for >> I'm going Republican.
>> Yes, sir.
>> That is >> It didn't seem that bad. >> He
really He really went for it. Holy
>> Okay, I You all get it. Okay, you all get it. We'll
go back. We'll go back to watch little more Alex Jones. All right,
we got We got about halfway through. We're about halfway through
the Alex Jones show. Okay, I know that that didn't seem relevant,
but it was very important to get that. Okay, we had to Old Twitch
was just filler, huh? Uh, no, I don't think so. That was pretty
funny. I think Listen, I think that was incredibly funny that
Oh, it's still there. He slumped back over and I never even came
to him. Hey, it's good to have you back, man. Glad blah blah
blah. Just Yeah. Okay, sure. Just like people say, "Why was you
around like that?"
Because I wasn't going to give him what he wanted. I knew what
he was going to do, but I wanted to make sure. It's one thing
to know what somebody's going to do, but it's another to wait
till they do it. And he did it worse than I thought. So Owen
thinks this new franchise is going to be talking crap about me.
He thinks this new franchise is going to be running down this
fabled operation, this incredible crew and our supporters that
are the InfoWar. Well, guess what, buddy?
You can up a rope. No matter what happens to this office of the
name Info Wars, we're gonna go on forever thanks to you can up
a rope is what Alex just said actually.
>> You listen
>> and the viewers, God bless you all. >> Okay, so
then we get on to an advertise. Oh [__] What is this
ad? Alex Jones video game. The >> is that anti-Semitic?
>> I don't. No. No.
No way. >> Am I anti-Semitic?
>> Yes. Yes. Yep. >> bro. Info. Oh god. Somebody
gave info wars access to VO3.
>> Oh, this is Gro Gro video.
>> The [__] are we watching?
>> This is incredible. Holy [__] Infowars are
the first platform to fully take advantage of AI video. Okay.
Alice Jones power plant something
humanized.
Kim said human seed. Kim said adapt
adapt odigen. Oh wait complex. Is this like AI too? Did they
like not get this correct and then it's just like a bunch of
words that don't make any sense. >> Alex on a top secret
shoreline mission to handpick nature's vitamin. >> That
looks nothing like the other
>> Before the globalists patent it. He's >> It doesn't
even look like him anymore.
>> Scooping it up like it's Cyber Monday in the supplement.
>> Top Bronson made this. >> Top Bronson. We found
out how Top Bronson is here. He's also doing the same work for
Infowars. Okay. Top Bronson, Rhodox, Tape, all Neorak, all these
guys. They're all working for Alex Jones, too. >> But suddenly,
the 20 foot tall seaoss mutant erupts from the tide pool like
>> Where's that? Gra on the bottom left. bottom right.
>> It's Grock videos. Grock videos for sure. Okay. Um >> I
was gonna say though, this is like uh Fat Ninja season. Okay.
It's like that's that's what this is reminded me of. The AI videos,
the little stories. >> Alex dashes like he just saw a new
Fouchy vaccine. Will he make it or become the monster's meal?
To be >> And by the way, I'm going to say this. The tough
guy owner, the smartest guy in the room, Mr. know it all. Thinks
he can run a publicity stunt to hurt our operation for his own
gain. I didn't bring out the bad stuff. So, go ahead and run
your mouth some more. And go ahead. You got some bad stuff going
just more. Just do it. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Like Elvis says, "Well, if you're really desperate and pay me
more, but I'm going to promote my new show on your station."
And I just said to him 5 minutes before, "Well, if you're doing
something new, great. you know, with these new backers we've
got, if they shut down Info Wars, we're going to go to, you know,
20 hours a day and like to work with you again. I went, "Nah,
I don't think so." And I was just talking to Harrison out in
the hall during the break. And he said, "Yeah, we thought Info
Wars was going under cuz the crew didn't really believe me. We
were going to beat him and we also have a backup, which we do
now. They know that. I understand, you know, that they didn't
know back then. Now they really believe because we survived a
bunch of these attacks." He said, "Oh, oh, that's great. Well,
I'd like to work with you. Maybe we should do a show once a week
together and kind of keep the old team together." somehow I want
to go, "No, I'm working alone." And and and that was the attitude
was
he wouldn't even talk to anybody for years here in the office
and just went completely cold. I'd be like, "Hey, let's go out
and get a steak sometime." Nah, it's all right. And he'd pull
up in the parking lot, just get out and just look at me like
I mean literally
he walked by me just go look me from the feet up just go, "Yeah,
right." I mean, you talk about an arrogant person.
He should star in the new American Psycho. Hell, he should. They
need somebody to run for, you know. >> Hey, Alex knows
who Patrick Baitman is. Let's go.
>> California governor after Newsome leaves. I said,
>> right? That's why I asked. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
I started from earlier in the stream. I was not paying >> I'll
move out to California. >> I wasn't thinking. I spoke without
thinking. God, >> he can do it. He's in love with himself.
He's he's he's he's
>> he's worldly.
Um, and
I'm glad I let it mature until the big fat tumor was right out
in the open so everybody could see it. But it was worse than
I thought. The big tumor I thought was there was that was just
the the the tip of it. And so it's a real shame. Real shame.
But I've been stabbed in the back so much and people lie about
me so much that
I've taken the high road every single time. And and this is the
high road because if I let him sit there and tell all those lies
he did, he'll just make a cottage industry out of it. That's
what these people do. Former employees say that, you know, there's
a fishbowl and I grab the fish out and eat it. Has there ever
been a fish or a fishbowl here?
And and you know, just just all sorts of of insane crap and I
just put up with it. But but here's the difference. I wasn't
friends. I mean, I I liked them. I knew him, but I didn't hang
out with them hundreds of times at restaurants and bars. I didn't
go on trips with them everywhere. I didn't shake their hand and
laugh. And he was a funny, nice, sweet guy. But even before he
went to prison, he turned nasty. And all I can say is he's unrecognizable
from the old Owen Shroyer. Dude, he's actually doing the prison
changed him